treat yourself with kid gloves ah well  it doesn't hurt because their kid gloves  this is the best I can do with my little  red mitt what do I mean by that that  means be easy on yourself this weekend I  had an invitation last minute to go to  the beach to fire island outside of New  York and I almost didn't go because I  was like oh I can't i gotta write blogs  I gotta do this I gotta do that there  was all this work I had to do and I  started beating myself up and judging  myself and saying jani you can't go  because if you go you know you're a  failure you're lazy you're not working  hard I wasn't cheating myself with kid  gloves I was punching myself in the face  so be gentle with yourself whether  you're starting a business or you're in  the media you're gonna get it done you  are gonna get it done treat yourself  with kid gloves be gentle believe  believe believe